-Kendall, thank you so much
for coming back to our show.
-Yeah, thanks for having me.
-You look gorgeous, oh, my gosh.
-This is so nice to be back.
-Yeah, it feels good
to have an audience, right?
-Yeah, it does.
-I want to get
into some cool stuff here,
but I want to say first,
your sister Kylie
is expecting her second child.
-She is, she is.
It's really exciting.
-Congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-How did you -- How did you --
How'd you hear the news?
-She called me,
and I answered the phone,
and she just had
her little sonogram -- like,
a picture of her sonogram.
And I was like, "Oh, my God."
I wasn't really shocked
'cause I, like, felt like
it could happen someday soon,
but I was excited.
I was very excited, and --
It's just a blessing,
it's amazing.
-Are you a good babysitter?
-I'm all right.
I always want to be, like,
the cool aunt and, like, liked,
I guess, by all of them.
-Yes! Yeah, me too.
-There is 18 of them now,
going on 20.
There's two on the way.
-Is that correct?
-So, yeah, my brother Burt
has one on the way,
and then, my sister, obviously,
just announced hers, so...
-Oh, my gosh.
So you're pretty used to it.
-I have a lot of them.
But it's fun.
It's really fun.
I try and be chill.
-Yeah. Does your boyfriend
help out at all?
-He loves them.
Him and Stormi
have an amazing relationship.
She has
the biggest crush on him,
and I'm, like,
jealous sometimes.
I'm like, "Stop."
-Yeah, you're like,
"Come on," yeah.
-I'm like, "Can you guys not?"
-"I'm the cool one," yeah.
-Yeah.
-Devin Booker
is on the Phoenix Suns.
He's amazing.
Just won a gold medal.
-He did, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's awesome.
-I know that we talked about it.
You were very sporty
when you were growing up.
You played basketball.
-I did in ele--
Er, yeah,
middle school
I played basketball.
-Do you guys ever have a little
one-on-one competition?
-We do sometimes. He --
We actually were just playing.
We have, like -- our friends
had, like, a pool setup.
You know, the hoops
that are in the pool?
-Oh, there you go.
-And so we were playing
in the pool, and he just, like,
took it way too seriously --
as did I, by the way.
[ Laughter ]
And I was like kind of --
-Dunking on you and stuff?
-I had the ball,
and he was guarding me,
and it was a whole thing.
He actually ended up
cutting my hand open a little
with his nail.
[ Laughter ]
'Cause he took it
a little too seriously.
It's pretty much healed now,
so you can't really see it,
but it was a big gash, and it
bothered me for like two weeks.
-Oh, my gosh, yeah.
Plus, you probably
had pool hands, too,
for being in there, yeah.
I saw you last night
at the Met Gala.
-Yeah.
-And you looked stunning.
-Thank you.
-Look at this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I mean, holy moly.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
-How long does it take you
to get ready for these events?
-That took
probably like two hours.
-Yeah.
-Which --
And it was, like, calm.
-Yeah.
-Like, I wasn't --
Usually, I feel like
I'm a little more nervous...
-Yeah.
-...most years,
and I was actually really just,
like, calm.
I told myself before, I'm like,
"Why stress yourself out
with unnecessary nerves?
Just, like, be chill."
-I felt safe with all the COVID.
I think they did a good job
with it.
-Yeah, I felt like they did a
really good job with everything.
You were the first person I saw
when I walked in with my mom.
-It's almost like I greeted
everyone on their way in.
-Well, by the way...
-They were like,
"Get to your table, Mr. Fallon."
[ Laughter ]
-That's exactly
what my mom does.
She'll stand at the top --
every year, she stands
at the top of the carpet,
and security's like,
"Come on, ma'am. You have
to kind of go inside now.
You can't just stand here
and wait around."
And she's like, "Absolutely not.
I'm standing here and watching
all my daughters walk in."
And she's just so cute,
and she takes videos of us.
The smile on her face
is just everything.
-She's the greatest.
-She's the best.
-Yeah, I loved seeing her,
as well.
You're stepping into a different
role in the fashion world.
You're the creative director
of this brand, Forward.
How do you --
When did you start that,
and what does that entail?
What is that?
-So, Forward is a luxury
online retailer, so they --
Yeah, they sell a bunch of,
like, luxury brands online,
and it's really cool.
I think, for a long time,
I was obviously in one space
of the fashion industry,
and so it's cool
to kind of take a role
in a more creative way,
personally.
So it's cool.
-Like, you do, like, a --
like, choosing what goes --
-Yeah, so I get to choose, like,
what is featured on the website,
and I actually had my first day
on the job the other day
here in New York,
and I got to, like,
go around to a couple designers
and pick things for the website,
so it's actually
really, really fun.
I get to, you know,
shop a little, so...
-You get to influence
a lot of people.
There was a giant headline
because you had
the fashion world
going crazy because --
-Oh, no.
-Oh, very controversial.
You wore Crocs.
-Oh, my gosh.
-You wore Crocs.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I -- [ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now the audience is
on your side here, but what --
-Yeah, yeah. Right.
-But I've never worn Crocs.
Questlove swears by Crocs.
-They're the best.
-Questlove is always, like,
"Dude, I lived long enough,
tried every sneaker,
shoe there is.
Crocs is my jam."
-Are you wearing it right now?
-Yes, I am.
-Nice. Oh, I'm jealous.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm jealous.
-You're jealous? Yeah?
Are they that comfortable?
I don't know what --
-They are.
I actually -- I saw those, like,
just on some, like,
Instagram inspiration, like,
fashion page,
and I was like, "Wait.
These are actually cute,"
so I went out of my way
to buy those specific Crocs
but was not expecting to be
photographed that day, clearly.
I'm really, really comfortable.
-Yeah, that's a comfy outfit.
Yeah.
-They're great.
I am not ashamed whatsoever.
-So, something like this
could maybe end up
on Forward if you feel.
-Yeah.
-Okay, yeah.
-Yeah, as Forward's
creative director, I approve.
-Right?
-I approve.
-I will tell you what
I approve of, and that is...
-Oh, my gosh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whoo, doggie!
-Yes.
-Let me tell you something.
It's delicious.
-Thank you.
-What made you get
into the spirits business?
-So, actually, my parents
were longtime lovers.
I grew up hearing about it
around the house all the time.
And so, kind of as I've got
older and, you know, drank,
I was always a tequila lover.
It's always my go-to drink,
and me and my friends,
it's all we drink.
And, you know, I kind of --
was kind of the friend
that was always trying
to find new tequilas,
tequilas that not everyone
might know
and just loved always
experimenting with it
until, you know, I kind of got
to a place where,
although I found
a lot of tequilas
that I really, really loved,
I didn't really see one
for my generation,
something that was, like,
approachable
and aesthetically pleasing
and socially aware
and gender neutral,
and there's, like,
so many things that I just
didn't really see
for my generation.
And so when I kind of
dove into it
and did a little bit
of research,
I found that
it was predominantly
a male-dominated space,
and that kind of,
coming from a really strong
female family,
it just drove me even harder
into the space
and made me really excited
to get into it.
And then, even diving
even further into it,
I found that, you know,
not a lot of brands that I saw
were as, you know,
friendly to the planet
as they could possibly be,
so I took that upon myself
to make that a really big part
of us as a brand.
-Good for you.
-So we've actually partnered
with 1% for the Planet
to donate 1% of our revenue
to planet-saving initiatives,
and then, along with that --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, it's cool.
Along with that --
Sorry, this is a mouthful.
Oh, my God.
-Yeah, go for it.
I like it.
-We actually --
at our distillery, which I was
just at the other day,
we found a way to take
the agave waste --
the agave fibers
and the water waste
and build the sustainable brick
that we are actually donating
back to the community
of Jalisco, so it's,
along with saving the planet,
it's important to us
to be friendly to the community,
as well.
-I thought you were gonna say
you're gonna turn them
into Crocs.
-No, no.
We're donating them
and building homes for people
that need homes, and there's
a half-built hospital.
-Actual bricks?
-Yeah, but they're all
sustainable.
They're made from the waste
that comes from making tequila.
-Congrats, buddy.
We love you and your family,
and they've said some things
over the years that have
become iconic quotes.
-Okay.
-And so we wanted to put
your knowledge to the test in
a new game called "Who Said It?"
-Perfect.
-♪ Who said it? ♪
♪ Tell me who said it, yeah ♪
-Why am I nervous?
-How it works is I'm going to
read you real quotes that you;
your sisters; or your mom, Kris,
have said,
and you have to tell me
who said it.
-Okay.
-Here we go.
-I feel like I'm not going to be
good at this.
-First up, here we go.
Who said, "Would you stop taking
pictures of yourself?
Your sister's going to jail."
[ Laughter ]
-That is actually one
of my favorite moments,
so I know exactly who this is.
It was my mom.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
-Let's see who said it.
Here we go.
-Kim, would you stop taking
pictures of yourself?
Your sister's going to jail.
[ Laughter ]
[ Ding! ]
[ Rimshot ]
-Who said, "Honey, would you put
a bumper sticker on a Bentley?"
-Kim. That was her thing
she would always say.
-Let's see who said it.
-Honey, would you put a bumper
sticker on a Bentley?
-Yeah, that's exactly right.
Good, you got two.
[ Applause ]
This one might be
my favorite one.
Who said, "You're cute jeans."
-Me.
[ Laughter ]
-I think you're right.
Let's see who said it.
-Those are cute jeans.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I don't even know,
like, what that was.
-Dude, that was just
saying to your mom
that you love her, yeah.
-Exactly.
-She's cute.
"Those are cute jeans."
"Yeah, you're cute jeans."
-Exactly.
[ Laughter ]
-I love that.
That's my favorite quote.
Who said, "But just knowing
you're a badass bitch
is just all what life is about."
-I really don't know this one.
Oh, no.
-"Just knowing
you're a badass bitch
is just all what life is about."
-Khloé. I'll guess Khloé.
-Let's see who said it.
-But just knowing
you're a badass bitch
is just all what life is about.
-That's what I'm talking about.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It was Khloé.
[ Rimshot ]
-Of course it was.
-[ Laughs ] Oh, no.
-Oh, no.
-This might be
my other favorite.
"You're cute jeans" is my other,
but this one's a great quote.
"A, B, C, D, E, F, G,
I have to go."
[ Laughter ]
-It's Kourtney and it's so good.
-Watch this.
-A, B, C, D, E, F, G,
I have to go.
-What the heck does
A, B, C, D, E, F, G mean?
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's really good.
-What does that have to do --
-Scott's reaction is everything.
-Scott was like,
"What's A, B, C, D, E, F, G?"
-By the way, you have to find
the extended clips of all these
because they end up getting
into funny moments afterwards.
It's really good.
-But did she forget H?
Is that the way it works?
Like, "A, B, C, D, E, F, G, H,
I have to go."
-Oh! Yeah, I feel like she did
say it wrong, by the way,
'cause I think it was
a meme or a quote.
-I don't know what it is
but I love it.
-And she tried to use it
and kind of botched it,
but it became a whole thing.
It's all over TikTok, I guess.
-It's all over TikTok, yeah.
I love that one, though.
That and "you're cute --" Oh.
Who said, "Rise and shine"?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, this one's --
Kylie, obviously.
-Yeah, here we go.
-This one's good.
-Let's take a look.
-♪ Rise and shine ♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Ding! ]
-That's what I'm talking about.
Kendall Jenner!